plenty of moves made in 2019 before the
season started so let's look back now
that the regular season is over were
they right let's start with otto beckham
jr traded from the giants to the
cleveland browns chris sims were the
giants right to trade obj well
i mean i vote you know i i don't know
where to even start with this i mean
because from their perspective yes they
were from my perspective no
no i mean i think they had had enough
you know just of odell beckham jr i
think there was some scare you know they
were a little scared that he might pull
somewhat of antonio brown type tactic
and force his way out of town uh i think
there was that issue of course the
jocena anderson interview with little
wayne i mean come on the giants are one
of the the giants the maris the tish's
their old traditional families there
they don't want to see that type of
stuff so i think they had had enough but
when i when i think about this i go oh
daniel jones saquon barkley and odell
beckham jr if they were going into this
next year i would say watch out giants
so
you know i guess if you're making me say
yes or no i'm going to say
we're the giants right to trade obj no
they weren't they weren't and they had a
special special receiver and i think
they could have helped their number six
pick out in the draft a lot if he had
him to throw to this past year
i think they weren't right to trade him
after they signed him i think that they
screwed it up that's a good point giving
him 20 million dollars and remember dave
gettleman the gm of the team said last
year we didn't sign him to trade him
they did get scared but they knew
everything that they knew when they
traded him they knew all of that stuff
when they signed him and that's when
they should have traded him that's when
maybe they could have even gotten more
than they got when they traded they
picked up
oh sorry sorry i don't know
i just wonder this with odell
like would it have been different if
they would have told them they were
going to take a quarterback in the draft
or do something like that you know maybe
were his frustrations with eli manning
and lack of aggressiveness and lack of
making wanting to stand in the pocket
and make throws down the field was that
his frustration too and would have
changed if they kind of gave him a
little inkling to go hey we're going to
draft the quarterback at six this year
i'm just wondering
and look at his frustration in cleveland
if they bring in a guy like josh
mcdaniels that frustration potentially
goes away because all of a sudden it's a
lot like the patriots so let's power
through these others sorry were the
patriots right to trade for muhammad
sanew well yes they needed it did it
work out the way they envisioned no it
has not muhammad saneu there's a reason
the atlanta falcons took calvin ridley
in the first round of the draft two
years ago because muhammad sununu is 30
years old he's getting at that age where
wide receivers start to lose a gear and
that was a guy that was not incredibly
fast already so yes they were right to
trade for him because they needed it
they needed this player and they felt
like they were a super bowl caliber team
uh has he delivered the way they wanted
him to no he is not
i i agree with you there i mean they had
the need uh he hasn't been emanuel
sanders no definitely not he has been
for the 49ers but still it's better than
what they had right how about this one
where the dolphins right to trade for
josh rose and i say yes you tell me what
you think i think yes too i mean what
was the
what was what was the the big risk there
you know it was it was a little risk
with a huge possible reward right like
oh okay what did they end up what did
they trade for them i can't even
remember for it now well it was the
second round second
what
and and it was six million over three
years that is a very affordable backup
quarterback contract in today's nfl yes
you get a chance to evaluate him see if
he's going to be your guy franchise
quarterbacks are so few and far between
you get a chance to evaluate a guy you
do it and you evaluated him and it's not
him but that doesn't mean you were wrong
to do it i'm with you i wish we
disagreed on that i thought i'd put you
in a box
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports